bonjour à tous donc l'enquète des
policiers sur l'horrible assassinat du
patri du petit grégory fait quelques
progrès mais le mystère demeure en c'est
ce matin que deux personnes au moins
sont impliqués dans ce meurtre
et l'on cherche dans la famille celles
ou ceux qui auraient pu rédiger les
lettres anonymes adressées aux parents
de ce petit enfant
jean-claude d'arrigo un village en
colère un village qui parle de se faire
justice lui-même lépanges-sur-vologne
but à l'heure de l'indignation et de la
vengeance surtout depuis que le père du
petit grégory a laissé entendre qu'il
connaissait le meurtrier de son enfant
les conflits familiaux des villemin on
oriente l enquête policière vers la
famille de grégory une famille de 70
personnes en quelques heures avec une
exceptionnelle rapidité des enquêteurs
en isolé quatre suspects deux personnes
au moins dont une femme se trouvaient
mardi soir à l'endroit où le cadavre de
grégory a été retrouvé un indice
important des empreintes de chaussures
et des traces de pneus au bord de la
rivière autres éléments le texte
manuscrit d'une lettre anonyme adressée
à jean marie villemin le soir du crime
tous les suspects sans exception ont été
confrontés à ces indices à lépanges
l'étau se resserre autour d'un criminels
monstrueux tellement assoiffé de
vengeance qu'il a exécutée sans pitié un
petit garçon plein de vie